tunisia is in crisis after the president
sacked his prime minister
and then suspended parliament the u.s
the u.n and the arab league
have expressed their concerns so far to
no avail
president kai saeed has doubled down
firing his defense minister
and ordering a curfew and a ban on
gatherings
troops now surround government and media
buildings
his critics are calling it a coup but
seitz says he's carrying out the will of
the people
protesters gather outside the gates of
parliament and tunis
inside the grounds security forces and
military keep watch
the night before tunisia's president
sacked the prime minister
and suspended parliament for 30 days
supporters and critics of the move
clashed on the streets
this conflict will lead to blood flowing
people are hitting and hurting each
other
it's come to violence but why
people took to the streets to celebrate
when the news broke
many are furious about the actions of
their politicians
protesters point to the worsening covert
19 situation
and the country's deepening economic
woes
president kai saeed met with protesters
on the streets
and in a televised address he said the
move was completely legal
and in accordance with article 80 of the
constitution
he could suspend parliament much of the
outrage is directed at the moderate
islamist enchanter party
the party's german rashid ranushi also
the parliament speaker
tried but failed to access the
parliament grounds
he called the dismissal of the
government aku
it's unclear how the police and the
unions will respond
amid tunisia's worst crisis since the
arab spring of 2011. uh from all the
situation in tunisia let's talk to
rabib louis a journalist based in tunis
now we're hearing that troops have
blocked access to parliament this
morning what can you tell us about the
situation there
hello so the troops block the the
entrance
to the parliament to avoid confrontation
between
the two sides of the protesters because
uh
yesterday morning we witnessed clashes
between protesters
who are supporting president kaisei's
decision
and in the other side the protesters who
are supporting another party
against the president so in order to
avoid
this confrontation the army and force
orders are sitting in the middle and
they finally blocked the entrance to the
parliament
but still until this morning
we we can see these confrontations again
because
yes from yesterday many many tunisians
on social media
called for more protest in front of the
parliament especially
another supporters so even with these
measures i think protesters will come
protesters will come back this morning
to protest again
so the president has removed the prime
minister dissolved
parliament with the help of the army is
that really within his constitutional
power i mean it
doesn't sound an awful lot like a coup
doesn't it
well in the constitution especially in
the chapter 18
he had the right to announce those
decisions but at the same time
this chapter 18 stated that he need
to consultate the president uh of the
parliament
and the president of the government
something he did not
so i think it's hard here to to describe
it as a coup
or not but because at the same time he
met with the national
organizations he had the support of the
labor union of some political parties
and even the prime minister hisham
mishishi himself
announced yesterday his resignation and
he
said that he accepted president kaiser
decision so
in in in order to describe the situation
right now i would say that it is
confusing we still don't know
don't know whether it's cool or not
because we
we are waiting for uh the measure the
next step that
president kai said will take well we're
getting reports there that the
offices of news broadcaster al jazeera
have been raided that state media
buildings have been
surrounded that doesn't sound like a
very democratic
uh way of dealing with things
yes i think this is a threaten uh for
the freedom of the press and
uh the civil uh right yes it was
a shocking jester uh he did yesterday
but at the same time he he uh he
delivered his
speech last night to uh to assure
the public that he will not uh he will
not
slip back to uh to the uh
autocratic uh regime that he will
respect freedom of the press but at the
same time
that's why i would say that as a
journalist we need to
to be vigilant well it's threatened to
the freedom of
express but at the same time we need to
be more vigilant and
we need to take our our rights as a
journalist bro rabbit a louis there
thank you very much
thank you